so Harry Potter is that a book for kids  Christmas took chalice akio remote  repair Oh remember what you did you were  like obliviate so you're a Gryffindor  right no wait don't tell me  ravenclaw all the problems you're having  are because you're a Gryffindor and he's  a Hufflepuff everyone can see that yes  all the bad guys are in Slytherin but  not all slytherins are bad guys come on  [Music]  the cable bill stick out your tongue if  you can understand me do you wanna be  free it's 90 degrees out why are you  even wearing a scarf for house Pride  Mardle it's at you it was a free elf  it's okay it's because you're a  Hufflepuff  JK Rowling says she's a Hufflepuff she  only said that so people would start  shooting on Apple Bob James at the party  yet oh good thing I have my marauders  map let's take a look  oh it seems like he is there but but  he's with Jessica  [Music]